Your Majesty may I present to you the  greatest detective of all time  Sherlock Holmes and dr. John Watson  I love you Oh Sherlock Holmes  his methods are ingenious there is a  master of disguise  what have you done with Sherlock why  Watson I never left and his mind is  brilliant  angle of approach compensator open-floor  termination of this detail in buckingham  palace  solve this case in four days or I will  kill the Queen science professor James  Moriarty come Watson we have a killer to  catch up  shall we begin the autopsy dr. grace  Hart a woman doctor and possible  fortunately we have a real doctor here  would you like some heroin  [Music]  I have two days left to live so this  case Majesty would you mind if we had a  picture together  what's the girls going to take the  photograph I will take it you see it's  sort of a self photograph he's a real  fan I swear I never do this  [Music]  [Music]  you